[Music]
so um there's this woman who was once
named the richest self-made woman in
america kendall jenner no
really it's that one lady that can't
ended up being a con oprah elizabeth
holmes oh holmes yeah just self-made
right he said khan right now oh
no elizabeth holmes yeah she's the one
with the eyes are like this
yeah yeah i'll take the biotech company
later yeah the fake ass [ __ ] oh yeah
she was the world's largest comment what
the with the turtlenecks he founded the
medical startup theranos are thanos
theranos which she claimed would
revolutionize blood testing but turned
out to not work
she was just 19 years old when she set
up the company in o3 and claimed her
blood testing machines could run
multiple tests and diagnose diseases
using a single drop of blood whoa
[ __ ] incredible right in concept
investors were quick to splash cash at
what they believed was ground breaking
new tech and by 2014
you have to bounce it off something i
think you it's like when you drippity
drippity cheese that yeah yeah
cheese made
but she's not a stripper see so she
splashed it yep
um so uh they were quick to drippity
drippity rain uh at what they believe
was groundbreaking new tech and by 2014
theranos was estimated to be worth a
whopping nine billion dollars while its
founder holmes
had an estimated net worth of 4.5
billion and was named in forbes as the
richest self-made woman in america she
is the modern day enron she was dubbed
the next steve jobs actually at the time
and was hailed as a silicon valley hero
literally like this i'm talking like
goat [ __ ] wow
isn't this an attack on women
if it is we're going to take an attack
attack on con women yeah yeah yeah
you're taking her roses and so that's
that's what everyone says now you're
taking her roses what does that mean
well when they say you gotta give her
give their your their roses and so i
think you guys are taking their rights
doesn't she have like legit scientists
under her like how do they not know how
did she get away with this yeah so her
the way she said it she said in court uh
she admitted through her lawyers uh her
lawyers that theranos had made mistakes
but claimed that she never knowingly
attempted to dupe investors or patients
knowingly defensively i did dupe them i
didn't know as far as claiming it
she should have been like oops i'm a
girl what do you expect
that was like
glad she gets off yeah i'm like all
right you're free to go it's just like
case dismissed
not guilty defense lawyers uh told the
jury that failure is not a crime trying
your hardest and coming up short is not
a crime so that was kind of like their
stance that's their defense talk to my
dad dude
we're investing in like the theory that
this machine worked and then when it
came down to like proving it it didn't
but she didn't tell anybody yeah it
totally didn't and then she was just
kind of keeping keeping that thing going
because you know it's like it's like
putting a reservation on a tesla truck
and it doesn't actually work yet
yeah or it hasn't came
for a reservational last year for the
cyber truck yeah yeah when are those
coming i don't [ __ ] lie to me those
atvs are coming though it would be
fairly similar right sold out already
yeah and only the kids ones came out and
those were sold out the minute that they
dropped us i'm gonna buy one and then
it's already sold i'm not gonna [ __ ]
sell it in five minutes
so
a couple days ago she was found guilty
on four of 11 charges one count of
conspiracy to defraud investors and
three counts of wire fraud against
investors holmes who is now 37 is facing
jail time with each of the four guilty
charges carrying a maximum sentence of
20 years each in prison therefore she
could possibly get a maximum 80 years oh
geez that's going to come out what's
wrong with society when a man does
something like this okay here we go when
a man does something like the right hat
which hat are you going to wear yeah
bernie madoff
when a man does something like this he
gets away scot-free and not only does he
get scott away from scot-free everyone
goes yay
teach us your way jordan belfort's on
every [ __ ] cnbc show now what the
[ __ ] is that i don't know why you got a
movie made for him yeah and the movie's
great i love that movie this is a good
book did you read the book it looks even
better i'm not one of those people who
says the books better always but that's
how good it was just a good [ __ ] book
i know i feel bad
let's cut that i look like an [ __ ]
that's what you want
out of everything you've ever known
right yeah yeah i look like an [ __ ]
oh i can't be one of those i hate those
people yeah me too [ __ ] them
damn she's good though i mean in the
right in the right place the same power
there's a lot of social media people
that uh i gotta find these comments a
lot of people on social media that are
actually upset
that you know she's only charged four of
eleven you know charges and stuff like
that or um there's people that are
immediately in the comments saying
things like uh guaranteed reduced
sessions a sentence or like damn uh for
sure she's never gonna see a day in jail
you know what i mean i think there's a
little bit of that like she's still like
a you know a charismatic attractive
young woman you know and you never
really know what she looks like
she always wears these big glasses that
make her eyes look like she's in a cook
bottles goldfish bowl yeah she's [ __ ]
on drugs or something like her eyes are
always like
no pupils are sure they're just scaring
the [ __ ] out for marx
oh i've seen her before
she's seen you a lot too
you can't get away from those [ __ ]
things
they're following me dude
big eyes very nice eyes
i sell
medical stuff people feel like you know
um attractive or nice people don't get
like heavy sentences apparently that's
like they prove that as like that's not
the case well it's more isn't it more
based on like non-violent is it more
based on how big your tits are yeah
that's what it was that was the metric
i've never seen a big titty girl in
court i watch a lot
like i watch a ton of court tv and it's
never that well they're in the audience
they're never on the stand true yeah
yeah i think a big titted
girl can get get away with anything with
me anything what if she's really really
fat and therefore her tips are big
is it the same i don't know
what i mean
it's so stupid it tends to just
remind me of me
do you think this is also one of those
things where it's like um it's like the
the biggest version of it you know what
i mean when somebody goes like the
farthest distance like the richest the
most glorified uh forbes next steve job
because there was so much praise that
almost like the the bigger they are the
harder they fall type stuff or is it
like it would be i mean obviously it's
not gonna be fair justice all the way
around in every similar case right like
we are we're obviously joking about like
if it was a dude what do we really think
would happen
nothing because there's a parade
you know what i mean like there's got to
be some sort of uh
i guess um
men always get away with this [ __ ] right
every single guy does uh but i did see a
thing on that where like a big titty
lady got better tips
yeah that's i think that's the thing
yeah they set up a coffee shop and they
had like a medium titty lady and then
they had a big lady and the big t they
got more tips
and they had they had it be the same
lady by just inflating her bra
and stuffing that thing wow
just one of your old videos
seems like no i wish i did that it's a
really good video classic steve green
comedy good fit that would be a good
thing
the funny thing is like there are like
cons constantly all around male female
doesn't matter but they don't get the
publicity because it's the scale man she
was known as the number one most richest
and then they're like you duped us all
you [ __ ] so her her main victims were
also really rich right yeah
so shouldn't the general public be kind
of okay with well unless you i don't
know if it was a public traded company
so like the stockholders that can be
like everyday middle class folks that
put a little money aside and they're
like oh [ __ ] you man do you know how
long bernie madoff's in prison for
because he did the same kind of [ __ ]
what was what was his case
biggest [ __ ] fraud of the century man
i think a couple of those guys killed
themselves didn't they yeah
big time
bernie what's his name made off m-a-d-o
made off with the money
nice nice career choice when i do it
gold bro
why can't you hold diamonds bro take it
over
what about um
ted bundy right remember how like
everybody was talking about ted bunnies
like attractive and real hard so
charismatic today but when he's [ __ ]
mutilating bodies and stuff so like that
was such a huge talking point yeah to
the point where it brought that case in
for me you know that was crazy too
because during the time he was only
charged for like two people
so like everybody thought like oh like
there's no way
he was only uh for like two different
women and then afterwards when he
actually got convicted that's when he
told everybody that like yeah i killed
like 40 chicks
so it's like because he was like what
that's all you gotta pin me for man i'm
better than this i had 40 [ __ ]
like serial killers are like some of the
most stupidest narcissists right because
they're always like wait wait wait wait
wait you only get me for 30. what about
the other 150 i did yeah i mean that's
how they catch well i guess that's at
that point if they're already going to
catch you you might as well put your
stats out and that's what he did they
love that [ __ ] it's true yeah that's
true
yeah i don't know it's already a rap
genius they are with executing but then
they're [ __ ] dumb ass on the other
side it's crazy they're like i want you
to know i'm the [ __ ] goat yeah yeah
you know they really do like you better
recognize my [ __ ] put me in [ __ ]
canton
hello you're just giving me probation
wait a minute i deserve [ __ ] the
death penalty
what do you mean let me go this is my
life's work that's what they want he's
like that guy's taking credit for my
serial kills that sucks ass you know
you guys gotta fix this [ __ ] you guys in
the media you guys suck at this thing
plagiarizing my crimes yeah this prison
is not for murderers like me
he's like wait this guy tax evasion get
me the [ __ ] out of here he's like oh
cool so that guy kills two people he
gets maximum security here i have a
minimum security this is [ __ ] make
any sense to you
where's the [ __ ] mask in the live the
jacket the [ __ ] straight jacket man
i better be walking on a [ __ ] dolly
dude yeah
knowledgeable for parole
like the dude and [ __ ] you what was it
conair
oh yeah dude
yeah yeah
i got the whole world
that movie's so good
that's one that we have to watch and
review oh i [ __ ] love that movie dude
that's a good one so good we should just
do all old movie reviews specifically
nicholas casey yeah yeah okay let's zoom
in cigar what's cage is expecting now
with his wife yeah she's a little
japanese chick japanese one their first
day
he likes asian chicks a lot well who
doesn't that's true
[Music]
[Music]
you